Hallo, guten Tag.
Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzarzt tätig und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Bevor wir genau über Ihre Beschwerden sprechen, bräuchte ich ein paar persönliche Daten.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Gabriele Dizel.
Gabriele Dizel, könnte Sie bitte Ihre Vor- und Nachnamen langsam büchstabieren?
Aber natürlich.
Gabriele Gustav Anton Bertha, Richard Nieder, Imin Ludwig Imin.
Gabriele Ludwig Imin, Gabriele ist der Vorname.
Dizel, Dora Ida Imin, Sivitiodra, Zizepilin Imin, Elbe Ludwig, Dizel.
Frau Dizel, darf ich fragen, wie alt Sie sind?
Ich bin 64 Jahre alt.
64?
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,68 m.
Okay, und wissen Sie zurzeit, wie viel Sie wiegen?
Ja, das sind ungefähr 72 kg.
72 kg.
Okay, Frau Dizel, wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt?
Das ist die Frau Müller in der Bahnhofstraße.
Okay, und haben Sie Angehörige, die wir benachrichtigen sollten?
Ich habe angerufen, aber benachrichtigen brauchen Sie jetzt nicht.
Okay, und also, was wird Sie zu uns, Frau Dizel, was für Beschwerden haben Sie?
Also, mein Hausarzt hat mich nochmal hergeschickt.
Und ich habe immer wieder Oberbauchschmerzen ziehen oder hier hinter dem Brustbei.
Und er wusste nicht, was es genau ist.
Deswegen habe ich jetzt sie hergewiesen.
Brustbein, Oberbauchschmerzen mit Oberbauch.
Und hinter dem Brustbei?
Manchmal, manchmal.
Und könnten Sie die Beschwerden oder die Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Sind Sie erdukend, brennend?
Das ist immer sehr unterschiedlich.
Es kommt nicht immer, aber manchmal kommt es sehr oft.
Manchmal, alle paar Tage, manchmal auch alle ein paar Wochen.
Aber wenn die Schmerzen kommen, dann kommt es relativ schnell.
Es ist meistens so in den Magen gegend.
Es wird so eng, es zieht sich schnürzig alles zusammen.
Und ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich auch ein bisschen schlecht Luft bekomme.
Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, dass es eher so ein bisschen Druck auf dem Brust ist.
Aber es geht ganz schnell wieder vorbei.
Okay. Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Über einem halben Jahr.
Also sechs Monate.
Und gibt es bestimmte Auslöser, wie z.B. Bewegung, Belastung, sind die Beschwerden schlimmer?
Wenn ich jetzt nicht sage, dass ich manchmal das Gefühl, dass es manchmal nach dem Essen so ist.
Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, dass es einfach spontan kommt.
Spontan?
Und beim Ruhe auf, in Ruhe auf, schüpfen Sie diese Schmerzen?
Immer, manchmal, aber es gibt mehr in der Belastung, wenn ich etwas esse.
Bei Belastung haben Sie bemerkt, ob die Schmerzen verschlimmert sind?
Ein bisschen vielleicht, eigentlich.
Außer hat es schon mehrfach ein EKG gemacht, der hat langsam ein EKG gemacht.
Das war bisher immer unaufgängig.
Ich dachte, das hat nicht vom Herzen, aber da meinte ich, da ist bisher alles in Ordnung.
EKG war unauffällig.
Haben Sie auch Belastung, EKG, gehabt?
Ja, das war auch unauffällig.
Können Sie beim Schlafen flachlegen?
Ja, da habe ich keine Probleme.
Strahlen die Schmerzen in andere Körperregionen aus?
Nein, nein.
Wenn die Schmerzen kommen, wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 0 bis 10?
Das ist immer sehr unterschiedlich. Meistens ist es eher ein bisschen mild, aber ich würde sagen 3 bis 4.
Manchmal sind sie auch etwas stärker, 5 bis 6 vielleicht.
Dafür nehmen Sie etwas als Schmerzmittel?
Ich mag keine Medikamente, ich nehme nicht so gerne Tapioca.
Haben Sie Sortbrennen, Astossen?
Ja, und nach Fettigemessen verschlimmeln Sie die Schmerzen?
Ein bisschen, nicht nur nach Fettigemessen, sondern allgemein nach dem Essen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Husten?
Nein.
Gleichzeitig haben Sie beim Ben-Diese-Beschwerden auftreten, haben Sie auch Herzklopfen, Herzrasen?
Nein, an sich nicht.
Haben Sie immer ein Gefühl im Brust oder manchmal?
Es ist mehr im Oberbau, aber manchmal denke ich auch, dass es hinter dem Brustbereich ist.
Im Laufe der Zeit haben die Schmerzen verlagert, also gewandert?
Nein, es ist eigentlich immer gleichgewöhnlich.
Ja, immer Oberbau.
Okay.
Haben Sie bemerkt, ob es Hautverbung, also geldlich manchmal, oder Ihre Augen?
Hab ich so, Sie meinen so etwas wie eine Gelbsucht?
Nein, Gelbsucht.
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Okay.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Fieber bemerkt?
Fieber?
Nein.
Ich habe sie nie gehabt.
Haben Sie Nachtschweißausbrüche in letzter Zeit?
Nein, auch nicht.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit, Frau Ditzel?
Also das ist eigentlich ganz gut, aber ich habe kein Problem, weil es sich ganz normal ist.
Okay.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Gewicht abgenommen?
Nein, ich würde gerne ein bisschen abnehmen wollen, aber nein.
Wie ist Ihr Stuhlgang?
Ich würde sagen, das ist normal, aber ich habe nichts Aufregendes gemerkt.
Sie haben kein Diöre oder Durchfall, meine ich?
Ach so, nein.
Und sieht Stuhl ganz normal aus, oder?
Ja, da habe ich nichts zu verändern oder etwas zu verändern.
Haben Sie Belehmungen?
Nein, aber eigentlich nicht.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Probleme mit Wasserlassen?
Nein, ich muss manchmal öfters auf die Toilette, aber nein.
Manchmal müssen Sie oft auf die Toilette, warum?
Ja, man ist ja schon nicht mehr die jüngste Frau, ein bisschen älter.
Und drückt die Blase manchmal.
Wenn ich manchmal hauste, dann geht auch ein bisschen Urin ab.
Okay.
Frau Ditzel, besuchen Sie Ihr Frauenarzt regelmäßig?
Ja, ich war jetzt die letzten zwei Jahre nicht mehr ein Frauenarzt,
aber davor war ich auch eine Frau.
Letzte Besucht war vor zwei Jahren, ja?
Ja.
Und wann war die letzte Periode?
Oh, ich bin jetzt 64, das ist mir auch schon fast 15 Jahre her.
15, also ungefähr 49, 50, da machen wir.
Ja, ungefähr, ja, das war so Ende 40.
Okay.
Nun möchte ich etwas über Ihre Vorerkrankungen fragen.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen, chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, also ich nehme seit einigen Jahren etwas gegen den hohen Blutdruck.
Mein Doktor meint, mein Hausarzt, ich habe etwas hohes Cholesterin,
soll Medikamente nehmen, aber ich nehme keine Medikamente.
Ich mag das nicht so.
Und manchmal nehme ich etwas gegen die Schmerzen,
aber sonst habe ich nichts.
Schmerzmittel, was nehmen Sie als Schmerzmittel?
Paracetamol.
Das vertrage ich immer am besten.
Wie häufig nehmen Sie Zeltun oder häufig Schmelz?
Ich habe gesagt, ich mag keine Tabletten.
Ich möchte schon eine starke Kopfschmerz sein.
Seit wann haben Sie genau Arterell Blutdruck?
Ich habe seit 7, 8 Jahren.
Und Tabletten nehme ich seit 5 Jahren.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen?
Ich muss mal nachschauen.
Ramipräg, Zymphenikam.
Morgen oder Abend?
Morgen.
Guten.
Würden Sie schon einmal operieren?
Ja, vor 20 Jahren hat man die Gallenblase entwähnt.
Da hatte ich Steine gehabt.
Da ist ein Teil der Gebärmutter entfernt worden.
Da hatte ich so eine Miome gehabt.
Wann war das Gebärmutter entfernt?
Vor 7, 8 Jahren.
Wissen Sie, warum?
Miome war das Gebärmutter.
Dann hatte ich eine Kinie-OP.
Das war ein Minus-Kuss.
Auf der Seite.
Welche Seite?
Rechts.
Wann war das OP?
35.
Hatten Sie früher einen Unfall?
Nein, das war jetzt.
Sonst nehmen Sie andere Medikamente.
Frau Dietzer, rachen Sie?
Nein.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, schon, aber sehr selten.
Einmal, zweimal in Jahr?
Ja, ungefähr.
Wenn ich mal auf einem Geburtstagsfest bin.
Ich nehme an, dass Sie kein Drogen konsumieren.
Oder ich bin nicht mehr auf dem Geburtstag.
Nein, ich bin nicht mehr auf dem Geburtstag.
Haben Sie Alergien oder Unfall?
Ja, jetzt ist die Polen-Allergie wieder sehr stark.
Ich habe Polen-Allergie.
Wie ausserzig Polen-Allergie?
Wie häuschen sie?
Ja, die Nase läuft, die Augen rücken, ganz schön kräftig.
Das hilft mir ganz gut.
Das geht nur für zwei, drei Wochen und danach ist es wieder besser.
Machen Sie manchmal Sport?
Oder machen Sie manchmal die Wanderung?
Nein, ich bin völlig unsportlich.
Wir haben einen kleinen Grund, in dem gehe ich manchmal Gassi.
Sport mache ich leider nichts.
Gibt es bekannte Erkrankungen in Ihrer Familie?
Zum Beispiel bei der Mutter?
Nein, meine Mutter ist relativ gesund.
Er hat auch eine hohe Wutung, aber sonst nichts anderes.
Mein Vater hatte mal vor drei Jahren mal einen Herzinfarkt gehabt.
Aber das war wohl ein kleiner Herzinfarkt.
Das ist jetzt nicht so, aber dem geht es gut.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe noch einen Bruder.
Ich bin vier Jahre jünger, aber dem geht es gut.
Er ist gesund.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin Verheiratser.
Wir leben zusammen mit Ihrem Mann.
Wir haben zwei Kinder, aber die Kinder sind längst aus dem Haus.
Und sind die Kinder gesund?
Ja, natürlich.
Herr Dessert, was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Hausfrau.
Wie ist Ihr Impfstatus?
Mein Hausarzt hat es immer kontrolliert.
Die Impfungen sind alle auf dem aktuellsten Stand.
Wir brauchen keine Impfungen.
Erst nächstes Jahr ist wieder eine Zeckenimpfung dran.
Wissen Sie, ob Sie gegen zum Beispiel Hepatitis geimpft sind?
Oh, Hepatitis.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Das habe ich immer gefragt.
Und letzte Frage, waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, wir waren letztes Jahr im Bayerischen Wald.
Im Ausland waren wir nichts.
Okay.
Was haben Sie in den letzten Jahren gemacht?
Das war es.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, ich würde froh, wenn Sie mir sagen können,
dass ich hier noch Untersuchungen bekomme.
Vielleicht noch eine Information.
Bevor ich ins Krankenhaus kam,
hat mein Haushalt ein Ultraschall vom Bauch gemacht.
Ich habe mir gesagt, dass meine Baucharurta etwas erweitert.
Das bedeutet, dass es 4,5 cm ist.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es etwas Schlimmes ist.
Aber das soll auch kontrolliert werden, hat er gemeint.
Arurta Erweiterung, 5 cm, 6 cm.
4,5 cm.
Ja, wir werden
Sie erst einmal körperlich untersuchen.
Auf jeden Fall nehmen wir Blut ab.
Und Ihre Beschwerden
sprechen für eine
Magenerkrankung.
Aber Herzkrankungen kommen auch in Betracht.
Weil manchmal beim
Bewegung haben Sie auch diese Beschwerden.
Aber Sie haben gesagt,
es ist diese Schmerzen treten auch in Ruhe auch.
Es kann sein,
dass Sie eine Magengeschwür haben.
Also es kann viele verschiedene
Ursachen sein
oder es stehen viele Ursachen.
Bevor
Untersuchungen,
kann ich leider nicht genau sagen.
Deswegen bin ich ja hier, dass Sie einige Untersuchungen machen können.
Dann bin ich mal gespannt.
Ich hoffe, dass Sie bald herausfinden, was es ist. Vielen Dank.
Haben Kollegen noch eine Frage?
Haben Sie T-Schul oder schwarze Stuhlgang?
Was ist ein T-Schul?
Ja, T-Schul.
Was ist ein schwarzer Stuhlgang?
Schwarzer Stuhlgang? Nein, das bin ich nicht aufgefallen.
Haben Sie Schwinde?
Ich habe Schwinde, Sie meinen, ob ich mir Schwindlich ist.
Nein, Schwinde habe ich keinen gehabt.
Ich denke, eine wichtige Frage ist,
Herr Thujan, heute haben Sie keine Zeit.
Deswegen, als das geschieht,
soll ich Sie mal fangen.
Ein Problem? Okay.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberrath.
Haben Sie kurze Zeit für mich?
Ja, es handelt sich um eine
64-jährige Patientin.
Frau Gabriele Bitzel.
Er ist 1,8 m.
Sie ist ein
1,68 m groß
und 72 kg schwer.
Sie stellte sich bei uns vor,
seit 6 Monaten bestehenden
Schmerzen im Epigastrikregion
und manchmal begleitet von
einer der größten
Schmerzen.
Deswegen hat sie
ihr Hausarzt besucht.
Der Hausarzt
hat ein EKG geschrieben
und das EKG war unabhängig.
Das EKG war unabhängig.
Die Schmerzen
seien ohne Ausstrahlung.
Und auf eine Schmerzskala
hat sie
bei 4, manchmal 4 bis 3
Schmerzen
eine Schmerzskala
bei 4, manchmal 4 bis 3 bis 4
bis 5 und 6
eingeschätzt.
Sie leidet
unter manchmal
dort brennen.
Aber sie hat kein
Pusten
und die Frage nach
Ikterus oder Gelb sucht
wurde verneinert.
Und in
Rahmen der vegetativen Anamnese berichtet
die Patienten, dass sie kein
Fieber hat, kein
Schweißausbrüche, nach Schweiß
Appetit sei normal,
keine Gewichtsveränderungen,
Sturrgang sei normal.
Sie muss
oft wegen Wasser lassen
auf die Toilette gehen.
Sie kann flach,
es gibt kein Schlafstörung
und sie kann flach legen
beim Schnappen.
Sie besucht
Frauenaarzt.
Sie war vor 2 Jahren
im Alter
von 50 Jahren.
An
Vorerkrankungen leidet er
seit
2 Jahren.
Sie leidet
seit
7 bis 8 Jahren
an arteriale Hypertonie
und seit 5
Gramm Morgens.
Sie hat
Hyperkollesteronomie.
Sie hat bei
Hypertonerone
keine Therapie.
Sie möchte
nicht viel Medikamente
einnehmen.
Das habe ich nicht genau gefragt.
Warum nehmen Sie etwas dagegen?
Aber Sie auch
schalte, dass Sie nicht viel Medikamente
einnehmen.
Gut, okay.
Bei Bedarf, aber selten, nimmt sie Paracetamol wegen Schmerzen.
Bei der Patienten wurde vor 20 Jahren eine Kolelithiasistoktomie aufgrund einer Kolelithiasis
durchgeführt.
Daran wurde Knieoperation wegen sichern.
Und sonst nehmen sie keine regelmäßigen Medikamente ein.
Sie hat nicht mehr Alkohol an Besonderanlässen, mal zweimal in Jahr.
Sie leidet und hat eine Polynosis-Hoschnupfen.
Da nimmt sie Settrysinn-Tabletten und momentan treibe sie kein Sport.
Bei der Familienanamnese ergab sich, dass die Mutter der Patienten an Arterelle Hepatonee,
der hat drei Jahre einen Yokartinfarkt.
Sie hat einen Bruder, der gesund ist.
Im Rahmen der sozialen Anamnese ergab sich, dass sie verheiratet ist.
Sie hat zwei gesunde Kinder, die erwachsen sind.
Sie ist Hausfrau.
Die Impfstatus ist aktuell und Reiseanamnese ist unauffällig.
Darüber hinaus erwähnt die Patienten, dass die Patienten eine Aorta-Erweiterung,
die eine Aorta-Anerysm festgestellt ist.
Wer hat das festgestellt?
Hausarzt.
Mit Abdominal-Auta.
Aneurysma.
Aufgrund der anamnistischen Angaben ergibt sich der Verdacht auf eine Corona-Herzkrankheit.
Und Gastroesophagealreflex kommt als differential diagnostisch.
Gastroesophagealreflex, Krankheit und Gastritis.
Und Gastritis, Duodenal, Ülser kommen in Betracht.
Zur weiteren Abklärung werde ich folgende Massnahmen vornehmen.
Um Krankheiten auszuschließen,
eine Ergo-EKG nochmal können wir veranlassen.
Und Epo-Kardiografie ist auch wichtig.
Die Beschwerden sind chronisch.
Und Blutabnahme, Blutbild, Hemoglobin und Entzündung, Parameter sind wichtig.
Wir müssen sagen, es kann eine chronische Gastritis sein.
Was brauchen wir dann noch, wenn sie das bisher noch nicht hatte?
Endoskopie brauchen wir.
Und bei bestätigten Herzkrankheiten,
vielleicht sollten wir auch eine Coronar-Angiografie durchführen.
Wir wollen damit sagen, bei Verdacht auf coronaren Herzerkrankungen,
als auf KHK, sollte man eine Coronar-Angiografie durchführen.
Von der Klinik her würde es dazu passen.
Wir können die Kardiologen noch mal dazu holen.
Wir wollen noch mal befragen.
Falls ihr noch andere Differenzialdiagnosen ein,
was sollte man nachgucken?
Pancreatitis kommt auch in Betracht.
Pancreatitis wäre sicherlich auch eine gute Idee.
Dafür sollten wir ein Bauch Ultraschall.
Aber es wäre sinnvoll, auch wenn wir Abdomen-CT veranlassen.
Genau, da kommt jetzt die Frage.
Wir wollen ein CT machen.
Wenn sie auch eine Bauch-Aurte hat,
sollten wir auch die restliche Aurte untersuchen.
Ob eine automatische Erweiterung vorliegt.
Oder eine Aortendisektion vorliegt.
Da hilft eine CT-Angiografie.
Das war ein guter Hinweis.
Sind noch andere Ideen von den Kollegen?
Keine Fragen.
Dann können wir schön zusammenfassen.
Das war ganz okay.
Sehr korrekt.
Das ist ein sehr guter Hinweis.
Die Überweisung der Erfolge durch den Haushalts- oder
die Beine des Haushalts- und die Erfolge des Haushalts-
und die Erfolge des Haushalts- und die Erfolge des Haushalts-
z.B. die Erfolge, das kann man schon sagen.
Weil die Patiente anders ist,
ob, wenn die Patiente mit dem Rettungswagen oder
der selbstständig gekommen ist,
mit der WhatsApp-Einstellung sei wichtig.
Sie hat im Urlaub selbst geлыbert.
Komunist.
In der Notaufnahme selbst schon gekommen.
Das ist richtig.
Das ist sicherlich sehr sinnvoll.
Das stimmt ja.
Nicht gut.
Also, der Kollege hat das glaube ich ganz gut gemacht.
Vielen Dank.
Der Kollege hat das denke ich auch.
Und wird sicherlich sehr gut laufen.
Keine Hektik.
Schön langsam.
Aber Sie werden, müssen Sie aufpassen.
Mann und Frau.
Sie haben immer eher gesagt.
Weil ein Mann steht vor mir.
Ich denke immer, aber ja.
Aber das war ganz gut.
Die Zusammenfassung war gut.
Es waren sehr ruhig.
Haben klare Fragen gestellt.
Ich glaube, dass es ganz okay ist.
Und ich bin überzeugt auch in der Prüfung.
Da ist natürlich immer ein bisschen Aufregung dabei.
Aber wenn Sie da so jetzt sehr ruhig angehen, dann sollte eigentlich nichts passieren.
Und dann denke ich, dass wir morgen oder die Tage eine positive Rückmeldung von
Ihnen bekommen.
Das war der Punkt.
Danke schön.
Zu der Patientin.
Es war wirklich so.
Dieser Patientin hat wahrscheinlich, also wir haben sie nochmal zu einem Angiologen
geschickt.
Die haben einen Ultraschein gemacht.
Ja.
Dieser Patientin hat erstens eine Aortendisektion der Aorta Ascendens im torakalen Bereich.
Die hat eine suprarenale anerosmatische Erweiterung der Bauchaorta auf fast 5 cm.
Dann hat sie infrarenal eine Aortendisektion aus einer Rhythmie von 4,4 cm.
Dann hat sie eine atriobenöse Erkrankung und zwar der Aorta Iliacacumunis auf beiden
Seiten.
Und ganz oben an der Aorta Carotis interna links eine Stenose und rechts hat sie Plak.
Der Frau ist wirklich von Kopf bis Fuß verkalkt.
Die Gefäße sind erweitert und sind sehr kritisch.
Also muss man bei dieser starken Verkalkung und einer rosmatischen Erweiterung, höchstwahrscheinlich
davon ausgehen, dass ihre Oberbauchschmerzen und manchmal auch diese torakalen Schmerzen
wahrscheinlich ein Problem dieser Aorten-Anorysma-Geschichte ist.
Jetzt wird sie noch mal untersucht, bekommt eine Computertomografie, eine Angiografie der
ganzen torakalen und abdominellen Aorta, um dann zu entscheiden, ob sie ein Eingriff
braucht, was wäre der Eingriff beim Anorysma zum Beispiel einstahnt.